what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed hello everybody sophia
is with your favorite sisters
sophia
uh if you guys are watching the video
version you will see that we are not
together for the first time in 26
freaking episodes sophie and i
aren't sitting next to each other we're
in separate rooms
we are in separate rooms separate places
and if you guys can hear from my voice
no i am okay but i do have a massive
cold and i don't want to give it to
sistine and also
it's kind of hard to shoot a podcast
next to each other when we don't really
have like
proper microphones remember you guys
were in florida so it is
a bit harder to record this but it is
kind of weird you're like right over
there so it's not
terrible i know i'm looking out the
window and i can see you
it's just so weird hi sophia
um okay lots of exciting things coming
up you guys for one
valentine's day even though when this
releases
it was valentine's day and what have
happened it would have happened this
sunday which i think is a very day
romantic day for it to happen on a
sunday on sunday
it is kind of moody huh i know the
ambiance
oh we don't another year of being single
on valentine's day
have you ever had a valentine's no
no it's so strange my relationships
never lined up
to where it would fall on valentine's
day interesting
so every time you were dating someone it
would probably fall through before or
you were starting to see someone
but i do have a tradition how i spend my
valentine's day
i watched that horrible movie
valentine's day with just about every
actor
oh you know is this the one that has
like new year's eve
like it has taylor swift like it just
has the most random people yeah
it's such a bad film but i love our
celebrity cameo so that's how i spend my
valentine's day i think that's how we're
going to spend it this year too
we don't have valentines yeah were you
guys surprised
i did buy us a bottle of champagne
yesterday
did you i did to celebrate
it'll be my valentine i think
valentine's day is slightly overrated
you know it's funny i was actually maybe
i'm better
we're a little bitter but i was actually
on reddit the other day because i just
like to read people's
horror stories people's bad dates so i
just typed in valentine's day because it
makes you feel better
right and i just typed in valentine's
day to see what come up i guess surely
people are triggered by this holiday
there has to be something good
and you won't believe someone put a link
to this article
and i thought it was so funny i have to
read you the headline
it says cockroaches and other obnoxious
valentine's day gifts
for your ex so listen how what
listen to the level of pettiness that i
so
appreciate i think it is so funny so it
says if your heart broken this
valentine's day
you could be the bigger person and avoid
sending
your ex an unsolicited gag gift but
this is where i come this is me if you
decide to not take the higher road this
year
there are plenty of options to choose
from okay
and what are the options and this one
was my favorite one i'll just read one
of them
for five dollars at the san antonio zoo
you can name a cockroach after your
former significant other and feed it to
a bird
reptile or mammal
the level of pettiness are we ready for
20 more which i think is a good penny
you can even have the zookeepers feed a
frozen
rat to a reptile if that's too intense
they have five
options yeah you could decorate a little
box
that's hilarious that's hilarious wait
these are really
smart yeah can you know broken hearts
are really creative
i know right think about it like i would
have never thought of that so
if you guys ever have a broken heart now
sistine is giving you the proper
information
a cockroach or a frozen bug or whatever
you said
oh i wanted um speaking of just horrible
situations um cece and i
are you know
things just happened to us we're never
like the first ones to know about
something and this is one of those
scenarios where
florida um released a statement saying
that like
the water was contaminated and you
should avoid
drinking it at all costs even showering
in it isn't good for you
yeah like you need to close your mouth
like at a certain point they're going to
fix it but i think someone was messing
around with it
did we know of course not of course not
so
you know i'm doing i'm downing tap water
by the glass i'm wearing we are water
people we are
plugging this thing and when i say that
i was chugging it in front of one of my
friends
and he was like you know you're supposed
to not drink that
well you left out a part we've been
feeling so queasy
for days and by the way i'd like to
mention this is the second time on the
podcast that i've mentioned
my version of montezuma's revenge why do
i talk about [ __ ] so much i'm so sorry
i don't know i don't know but welcome to
the show no i
my stomach and our stomachs were so
funky for so long and of course
we had no idea we're drinking for three
days and finally it's been probably like
a week
and it's feeling better
finally a bit so idiot just dumb and
dumber over here
drinking some poisonous ass water
without any known in the world
we're freaking flowing like the nile
river it is a mess
and a half to say the [ __ ] least this
is
we're okay for our dating life this is
perfect we're okay
yeah is this why we're single about
valentine's day
absolutely i'm sorry if you don't find
poop funny or for a joke funny
dude have you seen the show um have you
seen the episode of friends with
chandler
when he's about to do a job interview
and the guy goes you have to do do it
and he starts cracking it's so stupid
but like so perfect
well it's just like the whole point is
that but like poop is funny
get over yourselves get over yourself i
don't know
let's transition to this great segment
from the poop joke to this
um so sapi and i were talking about
what we want to start doing more on the
show
and we feel like we tell a lot of funny
stories and we tell what we're doing in
our day-to-day lives
we really want to be more open and maybe
you guys are like
no you're open enough we are okay
you literally just talked about poops
stop being so open sorry
sorry sophie and i definitely want to
dive more into
our personal experiences what we deal
with on a struggle
day-to-day basis share stories what
we've gone through and sort of
how we're dealing with it because i
think a lot of people
hopefully can take a note out of it i
mean obviously we're not experts but
we've
gone through it like you guys yeah i
don't know
let's i just want to open up the
conversation again because
i think uh a podcast is fun when you can
do a balance of silly and goofy and take
something informational out of it
yes what do you say sophia i i
completely agree and i think cece and i
although we have nothing figured out we
definitely do have
some good tidbits of wisdom we don't we
don't take our own advice
that's for sure like you're gonna hear
this advice no do we put it
to fruition fruition no but
no but i remember we did something about
friends and people really liked that
and when people yes how unless they like
something
we really want to run with it so today
we're running with it we grabbed the bag
and we're gonna dive head first into it
on that note as well i
want to say most of the segments that we
come up with and talk about is driven by
you guys so we listen to
your questions we read your dm so if you
want to share a story with sophia and i
if you want to and it doesn't have to we
don't put it on the show or if you'd
like us to put it on the show we could
talk about it
anonymously of course please let us know
because we love
love love um just connecting with you
guys so make sure you
go to the apple podcast page write a
review
leave your questions and comments in
there that is the only place we'll read
it
sorry do not and if it's a four star
we're not looking at it yeah just give
it five stars
so one of the biggest things that i
think is
so necessary to talk about because i
think everyone goes through this
is self-esteem and growing up i know
cysteine and i were really lucky because
our parents
really enforced us to have a high
self-esteem they were always trying to
make us the most confident person by
giving us compliments or encouraging us
to go at it and do whatever we want and
really giving us that confidence but the
thing is
is that it's not always easy and it's
easier said than done
and yeah it all we want is to have that
natural ability to walk into a room and
just be that attraction to people yeah
but it's definitely not something that
people are just born with
you know what i mean like self-esteem is
something that really needs to be
nourished and taught and it involves a
lot of self-love
and a lot of practice and i think where
your self-esteem comes from
obviously maybe not obviously but for me
at least definitely stems with
insecurity because i mean what do you
think do you think it comes from
insecurity
low self-esteem yeah i think it comes
from insecurity i think it comes from
our negative self thoughts i think we
are
trained to think like that because i
know there's so many times in my life
where
growing up i would think something that
i was doing was really cool
that i was like oh this i was let's just
say
bionics we used to used to like make
legos do you remember bionics
and i used to if you guys know bionics
we used to
build bionics without the instructions
we were daily
oh no we were so so good so i used to
think that was super cool and i remember
this one moment where
i told this girl in elementary school
that i did it and she looked at me like
i was
um wearing a big balloon man suit with
like four eyes and i was insane and so i
kind of felt insecure telling anybody
about it and sometimes
it definitely i think is linked to being
a people pleaser
because i know sophie and i have such a
bad habit of this we'll walk into a room
and try to make everyone like us when at
the end of the day that is simply
impossible
for example we'll we'll go on a date
right and i'll
try to dress for what the person thinks
or i'll try to dress how they would find
me attractive
or i'll try to dress to not stand out or
or feel like appease them you want to
make them feel
like you want exact validation to make
you feel like oh i'm pretty
right but at the end of the day you're
walking into this restaurant you're
feeling all anxious like oh my god my
hair isn't high enough someone's gonna
notice that my shoes were the wrong
color or
my nail polish is chipped just dumb [ __ ]
but at the end of the day
people no one cares restaurant they're
just trying to eat their meal
they don't care no and the thing about
self-esteem and i
i i know cysteine i both like we have
this conversation all the time like we
actually have to hype each other up
all the time i think people assume that
when we walk into a room we have it and
we figured it out
we're faking it honey we're not 24 7
walking and feeling like a hundred
dollars like
the hottest thing ever caring about
other people's happiness
therefore putting your feelings aside
you will never
ever be happy with yourself never never
because people can see that too
and then people might even start to take
advantage of that
this that's the that's the key point the
moment
you let your self-esteem go the moment
you think you are less than
is when everyone takes advantage of you
and then that's when you get yourself
into shitty relationships
shitty friendships a toxic relationship
with yourself
and that just becomes a wheelhouse full
of just
negative negativity negativity and the
only way to get off it is if you
just curse part of my french but [ __ ]
own it
you are who you are like i i look i look
at sistine when we used to model
there were days where she would wear an
outfit and she just looks bomb i mean
cysteine has that model body like she
looks great in clothing you do
no shut up but i remember my self-esteem
when i put on the clothes i was like oh
god i look like a sack potatoes here
yeah i looked at sofia wishing i had
that body and she looked at me wishing
she had mine so you'll never
you'll see you never know but the point
of it was was that
on camera it translated so poorly like
my smile was awkward my body was awkward
like i couldn't just get into it like i
wasn't feeling myself
and i think that's the key to everything
is where when you
really believe that you are who you are
who cares i have high self-esteem i
deserve what i want and i'm gonna go get
it
everyone else is gonna come around you
that wants the same thing the right
people
and it's like i wish i was at those
moments when i was at those photo shoots
going like
i'm gonna own it like i have like oops i
have but
like i'm not gonna
so here's the thing like looking back
and hearing what you just said
i wish i could have told you this now
back then right yeah i wish i could have
said don't be so self-focused
right don't be so self-focused because
we are
obviously viewing the world from our
point of view we're viewing it from us
so everything that we experience is
our conversations our old relationships
our history
the way that we feel when we put on
clothes like everything is through us
right no one else can have that
experience so if
it's really easy to become self-focused
yeah but had you just you know erased
those thoughts and
and took away the installing of your
insecurities
you would have put so much self-doubt on
you like you are more than capable of
being there
and owning it and when you own it people
believe oh [ __ ]
that's she's killing it also why waste
your time
with these thoughts like i get mad at
myself for thinking why did i freak out
this entire day about something i wore
something i did
what i said because someone else may
have thought oh that was a little off
who gives a [ __ ] why why would i do that
but that's what makes you so likable at
the end of the day
the choices that you make the weird
clothing pics that you decide to wear
that night
it's what makes you you if you were
dressing for everyone else no one wants
everyone else
no that's what makes you attractive and
unique in an individual so
i'm happy that we're figuring this out
now at 22 24 years old
but i go i went out yesterday i went to
dinner and i
had these same thoughts i mean i still
don't have it figured out all the time
but i can tell you when i
check myself and i stop myself from
feeling this way
my confidence you guys it skyrockets
please try it
like literally look in the mirror if
you're nervous about how someone else is
going to view
your jacket tonight just say [ __ ] it i
like my jacket
and i promise you you'll walk in with
the glow around you it sounds so stupid
but it really works i always let things
this is what i want someone to do if you
really care about what you're wearing
and what people are thinking around you
go into a restaurant wear a certain
jacket right
leave come back a week later let's see
if those people actually remembered what
you wore that night
yeah no one cares no one around you it's
all about
with not even just close with everything
you do it's all about trusting your gut
trust in your instinct and trust the
choices that you make because
you know trust in that last risky text
that you sent
trust in all of those little things
because the second that you
think and you start to tell yourself i
made the right choice for me
you won't second guess any of the
decisions that you made therefore
you'll feel confident about it therefore
it'll build your self-esteem baby
yeah yeah so we do
have some tips and tricks to get this
because it is
not something you get in one day and you
have it for life it is
a tool it is practice you have to
reinforce it
all the time because you don't feel hot
every day
sophie and i have separate different
methods
of how we just little things that help
us right so
yeah i guess we'll say what each of us
do yeah
so one i'm a big quote person
word person so i will go on my phone and
i'll like
find some words of affirmation i will
repeat things in my head i'll say some
mantras before i go out
anything to just kind of hype me up i
don't know like or listen to some music
are you more of an audio person you need
to hear it or do you like to visualize
and see um i'm more of a visual learner
but at the same time
if you put on promiscuous girl
i will be ready to go but i'm just
saying anything that kind of gets me in
like
all right feeling myself mode i'm good
what about you
um it sounds so stupid but i actually
talked to myself in the mirror
it sounds so dumb but it'll look
something like this
sistine you look good
you feel good you've been working out
you've been eating right
you you're you're prime you're a prime
piece of steak baby
go out there and get it ground yourself
in that a1 sauce
that's exactly what i tell myself no so
i don't actually tell myself that
no i i think that like looking at
yourself in the mirror and
saying things that that you're almost
scared to say about yourself or
or don't hear from other people that's
really important
and you also i just had a thought about
you don't have to think you're perfect
and there are things that i know that
i'm like okay i need to change
about myself or i need to like maybe fix
um also you have a little gust in the
background
maybe oh my god the cat just came
in um what i was gonna say is that
um there are things that i you know that
you can recognize probably you want to
work on
so first and foremost own your body
own who you are right at that moment
then
i will go down and i'll write down
things i'm like okay i want to improve
this
um i want my butt to be perkier i want
to eat healthier i want to
not be so negative with my thoughts and
i will continuously work throughout that
week
and identify them be like okay i'm i'm
not going to do that
today i'm good you make a checklist i
make a checklist and it's not
and i know people are like oh maybe that
you're reinforcing the bad things you
don't like about yourself but i think
it's important
to recognize what you are insecure about
and learn how to grow it fix it or at
least
or at least get change your thoughts
because
you don't have to live with feeling this
way all the time
no at the end of the day it's a choice
and it's such a hard hump to get over
because i remember i was in a
dark place um two years ago and i felt
like
just a a pile of garbage to be quite
frank i felt terrible and i didn't want
to get out of bed till 3 p.m
and it was a choice that i put myself
there i surrounded myself with people
that put me there
and getting yourself out of that hole is
possible
it is possible so possible and also
change your thoughts about it too like i
used to not like
the way maybe my stomach looked in a
bikini for example
and i was like always so hard on it all
the time
yeah we're going back to it and anytime
i wore it i was like oh my god this is
embarrassing everyone's looking
i've had to seriously write write this
down and be like okay i'm gonna
consciously
not look in the mirror for like 40
seconds and think it's not perfect it's
not perfect it's not perfect
and just go outside and enjoy my day
what if what if you started to
say if you're like okay i don't like my
stomach what if you changed the dialogue
that you used so it wasn't so harsh
on yourself you know what i mean just
change it be like i love it
i love it and then yeah by the way oh
there was something
this woman this is actually really
interesting um advice this woman gave me
a long time ago
she was i think i honestly i was like
young i was like 15.
but she was i was looking at my dress i
forgot i was at one of the events with
mom and dad
and i was like oh my dress is ugly i was
in the bathroom and she came up to me
and she goes
i'm going to tell you a life lesson that
i've learned and i've been married for
40 years you see these legs and her legs
were like she's older so
it's not like the 20 year old legs but
she's nice like she goes
i tell my husband every day how hot my
legs are
and do he thinks i have the hottest legs
in the world
and she left and she told me that and i
never forgot it because i was like
that's true if you are telling your
significant other or yourself
constantly day after day that something
on your body or something about you is
not right
you are going to believe it's not right
if you are saying
my stomach is the hottest [ __ ]
stomach ever
and i look great yeah even to believe it
not even body even your brain
i am so smart i'm a fast reader i'm not
work
i'm like but like okay who cares i'm a
dork
that's fun other dorks join me
at the end of the day my mom always told
us about self-esteem she's like
just don't give a [ __ ] literally let it
go
just let it go let it go you guys the
things the minus things that you worry
about
i promise you in a week you won't even
remember the things that you were
stressing out about so much
so that's the most important when you
find yourself sort of in this rabbit
hole you're like
obsessing obsessing obsessing over
things that you know you feel this way
and you feel scared and feel small it's
like
walk into your room puff your chest out
talk in the mirror
just try little things just try it
things can always get better
i like sad not really okay i was just
trying to be nice
you didn't like it no i'm trying to
lower your self-esteem
i want to actually bring this up and i
think this is going to be very fun for
people
to listen to and i think you might get
some good advice from it
so sistine and i we're sisters
we live 24 7 24 7
together i know if you haven't figured
that out now
um problem but we're sisters we live on
top of each other we
pretty much look the same um we have
different personalities
and that can lead to fighting and
when i say fighting yes cysteine and i
have fought we have kicked we've
screamed
we have slammed doors we have done
everything that sisters normally do in a
fight maybe you guys are one
sister 101. sister 101 we're not perfect
i'm never going to act like and we're
never on this show ever going to act
like
we are perfect and we have it all
figured out and we are the bestest
friends 24 7. she is my best friend
but sometimes she wants to kill me and i
want to kill her
all the time that's the fact if you're
staying with someone for all
like 24 7 you want to punch them
sometimes
but i think um i think it would be
really interesting to talk about
sister fights and family fights and
family dynamics because
we also got quite a few questions about
about fighting
with your relatives and how sticky and
messy it could be
and you know it's for example
sophia and i what was the last fight you
got we got into would you say
uh like maybe week ago yeah probably a
week ago
oh i know it was about like business
probably like we were like freaking
business related that's definitely where
most of our fights come from because
just very different approaches about
everything just very different
and it ended up being a huge one of the
big ones you know
one of the screaming having to separate
for 30 minutes just to decompress
and it wasn't just us all three of us it
was oh yeah they all got roped in even
jennifer got roped in
oh my god the cat in the background is
very distracting
very distracting because like i think
day to day will have like many bigger
things but
it's not like it's just whatever and
we're so used to it now it kind of flies
overhead but this was like
a genuine fight last week yes
yeah and it got really bad like we all
had to take walks
we are some people are crying some
people are screaming it was just like
world war three at its finest but
we that's normally what it is like
whenever we fight it's also
usually two against one it's never i
know
again so unfair that's so unfair that's
like the one problem about having fun
and the funniest thing about us fighting
too is normally sophie and i will be
fighting
not so much me and scarlet or me and or
scarlet and sophia
scarlet's normally the middleman but i
think it's because they're so scott
equally argues with both of us right but
so this is what this is how you win a
stallone sister fight say if
we're debating scarlet will walk in the
room we'll maybe hear about 14 seconds
of the fight
and then just walk towards the sister
and like
take her stand and say it's the fear
you're wrong
you're wrong also and then your face
goes on your side
no she doesn't she went on your side the
other night yeah
that was honestly that was a rare
occasion and you know that
so she did go on your side but the
second scarlet goes on your side you've
lost
there's nothing you can do because there
are two voice boxes against one
you're done and even if maybe you're
potentially right
you are totally wrong it's like that's
the problem with it it's like
maybe if they're wrong and you're right
or vice versa yeah
you just never know but it's funny i cuz
we have
totally different fighting tactics oh my
god totally different
like i think it stems from childhood i
don't know how
how is yours i like i know yours but
explain yours
when we were children and we would fight
um we would wrestle a lot and
sophia was much stronger than me i was
like a skinny string bean
scary looking kid was very much like a
slender man
if you will and sophia could easily just
wrestle me down and like
she'd pin me down and say like oh well
you're wrong and i couldn't fight her
back she was much stronger than me
but i was able to break her down with my
words
yeah see that's where that's where i am
that's how she gets i feel like that
translates
to how we fight today but not not really
no i i think i'm different now and i was
gonna say
i did used to do that i used to be the
very much the screaming and i still do
i will say my energy level will go from
like
when i get into a fight zero to 100 like
my anxiety goes down
everything goes up like full blast full
anthem but you'll scream
until you win yes i will scream into one
but i also have realized that i've done
this about myself where i'll do that
and then suddenly flip and drop and go
yeah you do like a light switch like
crazy like a light switch
this is my personality with a lot of
things like with dating with guys with
friendships i'm very much a person i
will be
so so passionate so angry so
argumentative
and then i will shut it off and i can
shut it off
my tears have sucked back into my eyes
my face is neutral
it's very interesting you'll be
screaming like crazy right so if you're
fighting with dad
crazies yelling at each other i'll come
in why are you guys even yelling at each
other this
is stupid resolve it you'll walk back in
five seconds later
okay i'm sorry i don't want to fight
anymore and you'll be fine
for me if i get a crazy screen with
someone
i literally have to go to my room like
look in the bathroom mirror and just cry
i literally just like [ __ ] like that
because i hate because i'm a crying
cancer i hate
i hate confrontation and i hate other
people being upset with me
so much yeah but i have to it gives i
need like an hour
you do need to need like 24 hours oh
charlotte is like
she wallows for like ever and we're like
oh my god get over it
no but that's the one good thing about
us
is that we fight but we get over it
the longest i think we've ever actually
we're mad at each other we're
maybe like a six hours like if anything
that wasn't what do you think the
dumbest fight we recently got in was
um honestly i think it was over that
text message with that girl
no i got a better one which one
we got in a fight over a pack of gum
oh my god a pound a pack of
[ __ ] take five gum yeah you guys were
making fun of me
you guys okay well it's not my fault i'm
not going to make you sound bad
but sophia loves gum right i too had a
gun
we had a gum shortage in the house so
people eat like six to seven or
nine pieces in one chewing
so your pack is gone if you ever cease
to be on the street never offer her gun
because she will eat it all okay i have
like eight in my bag
so scarlett goes to the market buys one
pack i think she did it on purpose just
to rile us up she did just
yeah she just buys one pack and she
she hides it from all of us but i find
it and
i pulled it up and sapi goes give me a
piece of gum and we go
no and we're running away we're throwing
out each other
what started off as a joke got actually
serious we we're like oh wait
wait we're fighting about gum now what's
happening yeah i got so bitter i think
honestly i do admit that i was being so
sensitive i was
i don't know why yeah
i don't know i think i thought you guys
were making fun of me and i just took it
so personally um sometimes i feel
no i don't feel like this all the time
but sometimes when it comes like sister
things i always feel like
people are thinking like i mean i don't
know i feel like you two have like
having a plan
sometimes i'm like oh are they trying to
like mess with me no i know
that's how that's why that's why
fighting with family it's so stupid
and let's sort of circle back to the
point of why we even brought this up
yeah and why it's important to sort of
move on
and pick and choose your battles you
guys move on
move on at the end of the day i look at
cynthia's girl they're my best friends
for life
my mom always told us you're going to
have tons of girlfriends you're going to
meet in college and high school in your
job
and and when you even get have a baby
you're going to have a new group of mom
friends
so but there'll be no no one in your
life
like your sister best friend for life
you have a built-in best friend
i can't imagine maybe honestly
i know i genuinely can't imagine if i
didn't have these two in my life because
there's been so many scenarios with
friends and boys and things where
honestly i needed the tough oh
the cat is in the frame
yeah there's there's so many times you
are going to turn to your family
for that honest opinion that
support because i know at rock bottom
these people will be there and so i i
feel like we have that ingrained in our
brain and so
taking it back about the fighting and
our fighting styles and how we resolve
it
is when we fight normally
we will yell y'all yell we're all very
very big personalities too as you can
tell
very loud we do not like to back down
we will separate give each other space
give each other an hour
be in totally different rooms go on a
walk go on a drive all that stuff
think about but on your end while you're
gone think about the fight and how
important
it is to keep it going like is it really
yeah like when you get home
are you gonna bring it back are you
gonna keep it going is this gonna go all
night
or are you gonna come back and just go
okay
this was dumb i'm annoyed about it but
let's move on
i don't feel like arguing about it and
we're not talking about
argues about pieces of gum i mean
every family has gone through their
stuff there's they're serious [ __ ]
but it's all about coming out of it
together and i think that
is is so important at the end of the day
it's like you guys have these
there's no one in your life like a
family member no one
and also i think that but i think it's
also important to
listen to the other side i think you
need to be open when you get back
to the house cestina and i have to sit
down and go okay
i was feeling this way because of of x y
and z and seems like well
i was feeling this way about x y and z
and if you guys can't come to a middle
ground
then go okay i understand you you
understand me
this is the way i work this way you work
let's move on and let's just not ruin
our day
because it's like not worth it and you
know cece and i are here we're saying we
fight we do it all the time we probably
will in the next couple days
and we're gonna do exactly probably
fight right after the zoom call
we'll probably argue about how the setup
is right now what should we fight about
what should we fight about um
the fact that you have to take care of
the dogs i've been hanging out with the
dogs all morning
so yeah
well maybe i'll fight with you about
how we look sort of matching right now
oh yeah three people told us we looked
like twins
last week i don't think we look like
twins at all
all right make a twin face
i'm trying to do your face nah
yeah and we are back with
another segment of unsolicited
advice you guys from
can i have a moment i was going to be
part of can i be part of the jingle you
always start to drink
go go from your sisters
okay and sistine and mabel
the cat okay so guys remember once again
if you want us to answer your questions
please go on to apple podcast send us
that five star send us that review
and we will answer it on the show so
also
follow our instagram and our youtube
people yeah you guys our instagram we
upload really good
content and by the way we do it all
ourselves just letting you all know
everything every edit every post every
caption
we see everything so today we have
courtney from new york and she wrote
incarnate
whoa whoa okay oh my god um
obsessed with this podcast i literally
tell all my friends about it
we all wish you guys were in new york
city because you seem super fun
cool we do the same thing with hinge
it's a group effort
yes honestly you guys if you are on
hinge and you have
apple or what's it screen sharing
airplay airplay
do it show all your friends like a live
dating show
get a bottle of wine and joke through it
and your girlfriends will tell you if
it's a good or a bad match okay
so to the question do you have any
suggestions on dating
hinged during the pandemic and having
interesting combos since there is not
much going on
wow that is a very very um prevalent
question because i know that we're kind
of going through the same thing right
now so repeat the last part of the
question
it was how like what interesting
conversations to have during the
pandemic since there's not much going on
like we're
right i'm not gonna lie courtney i
deleted my hinge because there was not
much to talk about
i know i know i know the thing that i
found with hinge was
it was sort of easy to start
conversations because it's based off of
this questionnaire that's on your
profile so people can directly respond
to one of your questions in a witty way
but i guess for interesting conversation
i mean it is hard
uh well she said suggestions on dating
and hinge during the pandemic and then
having interesting combos
i feel like dating during the pandemic
it is a whole new ball game i feel like
people are
a bit obviously way more hesitant to go
out i think that it is
you have to be a lot more creative with
the type of dates you want to do
and i want to say from the conversations
that i had on hinge with people
it's sort of annoying but it's you have
to remind yourself that
there's not a lot of people out there
that can make interesting conversation
do you know what i mean you guys that is
such a true
and such a fair statement i'm so sorry
but
like courtney you seem like a really
cool gal and you seem like you
you can keep up a good conversation
right
but not a lot of people can so
it's hard to force it if it doesn't just
come naturally because i have had some
guys on hinge
that are funny and great and and we'll
just say random things that are
make the interesting conversation so
much fun but there are a lot of people
that
miss the mark big time
you know i i think i think not talking
about the pandemic
don't talk about covid don't talk about
what you're doing at work
yeah start bringing up things that are
your hobbies that are outside all that
like where do you guys like to travel
ask that question what is your favorite
animal what's your favorite drink
what's play a game with each other so
what i would do what i would do for
example is
one of my questions was
you could never beat me in blank and i
filled in chess
it was at the time when queen's gambit
was blowing up
so one of the best ways that people
would slide in they'd say
all right bet let's play a game of chess
right and then
we just get into a conversation about
that and where it started i'd say oh i
joined the chess club a lot you don't
have to
you don't have to join the chess club
but just be weird like just say
funny things because you might not even
meet these people that's true and if
you're actually planning on meeting up
with this person and you said you're
from new york so
i'm trying to think of the ways that
maybe you could maybe go to central park
and
i'm a little coffee and walk around i
love coffee
i think coffee dates people are sleeping
on them i would love
if you did a zoom date with one of these
guys
get put a ring light in front of you get
real dressed up
cue look bomb have a glass of wine and
just
talk that way it's perfect i don't know
why you get to filter them out
yeah you just hang up
but that's what i'm saying you get to
filter these guys out i think it's
horrible when you
go on this date and they suck and you're
like
all right [ __ ] i have to be here for an
hour but i can say that's
such a good point let me tell you
there's a lot of weirdos out there too
there's a lot of weirdos i actually got
a text from a guy
that i saved the contact as creepy hinge
chef yesterday
him you texted just be careful yeah be
careful
if you have a creepy hidden chef avoid
at all costs
i wish that i could give you advice on
dating
um but i am simply not doing it but my
advice for conversation is sort of
start as if you're already in the middle
of a conversation with someone just sort
of ignore the hey what's up how are you
where do you live what do you do
just sort of just start as if you guys
have been talking for two days straight
yes
i completely agree it'll just accelerate
yeah that's i think one thing that
sustained i do really well
and i think this should be taken um for
all dating advice like not just during
pandemic in general
b be and it sounds so so simple but like
actually be yourself your full true self
right off the bat if you are nervous
honey go walk around the block shake it
off and literally be
if you're a dork be a dork because let
me tell you that's more attractive
guys tell you that too they don't like
the games they don't like the cool girls
they don't like you know no putting them
on the weird questions if you have
something weird to ask
i would be messaging a guy i will say
the weirdest thing on it
the weirdest thing because think about
how many girls that they're messaging
think about how many girls that they're
messaging right
and you want to stand out some way all
of the other girls are probably just
saying
cute sort of maybe cheeky sexy things
trying to get their attention but if you
said something so
left field i just stuck out of nowhere
they're gonna be like
wait that's interesting that caught my
eye that's funny
yeah it's also reel them in confidence
reel them in with that so i hope
everyone
liked today's episode we definitely did
i actually loved
talking about self-esteem and our sister
fights it
it gives us a whole other side of us
being vulnerable of course we threw in a
little dating there
we're gonna try to not do that too much
because we have talked about sex and
boys a lot
so we do want to hear from you guys yeah
so if you guys do
have it any topics
some thrust them our way smack me in the
face with your topics
love to see it we love you guys thank
you so much for tuning in to this week's
episode of unwax
we will see you lovely love birds next
tuesday
bye bye